are you scared for the bus I'm a little
bit scared yeah terrified tell the
[ __ ] would tell him what's up yeah so
one crack another one is that the time
you hear this hopefully we're not
seriously hopefully we're not [ __ ]
dead we're going from Denver now to
Lawrence Kansas and the snow is real bad
and there are tweets from the Lawrence
PD about how the roads are just like
covered in ice and our bus driver this
morning was telling us some scary [ __ ]
about like what he went through last
night like he had to go around like a
four car pileup and some other [ __ ] and
I'm just like middle of night as we're
snoozing oh I mean I felt some of that
she does a violent ass riah dude
sleeping like baby deer I felt more like
a pregnant mother in a boxing match what
I just like I felt like I was in a
pregnant mother in a boxing match I was
getting thrown around hood weight you
felt like a fetus in a pregnant lady in
a bar in a boxing match yeah against
another pregnant lady no just like in a
street fight or something like I was
just like kitten who's street fights a
pregnant lady [ __ ] go to worldstar man I
bet you find one dude I was getting
thrashed I took two melatonin Chuy's
took me two little melatonin Chuy
melatonin
yeah Chuy melatonin well dude I got it
in the child section I got a very nice
chewy Meli's very little babies that
can't sleep for the nice care package
for my friends okay they gave me a
little chewy mellow Tony because they
know I got soft little baby teeth mommy
hurt my little baby lately too chewy
minute Tony
my little derf wants a little chewy meta
Tony I feed it like to myself like an
airplane before I go to bed mmm open up
what are you doing up there in a well
nothing
you sure it sounded like you were no
pull the [ __ ] curtain back babe on
wearing a diaper I raised her diaper a
couple hot wheels on your chest
stop it oh yeah I was getting to the
Rashed man I'm like I would wake up and
I'd like my leg in my arm would be like
off the bed and I'd be tripping like I
think I were just roll in my sleep yeah
I think I was just like rolling with the
motion or somethin I'll sleep on the top
a little bit sketchy definitely is
smaller yeah there's been a couple times
where I've rolled over and like kind of
leaned over the edge but like man if I
fall I'm gonna splatter that would be
such a brutal asphalt be great vine
though yeah so I pop out like the top
layer and they just [ __ ] right in the
middle cuz I think you go out and I
think you'd hit the other side and I
think you'd smack like you feel like
that kid on that slide I think that's
what it would be like like a [ __ ]
what's that [ __ ] in Japan um oh oh yeah
the ant anime no goddamnit
ramen ramen [ __ ] huh Honda yeah it's
like Honda yeah right the [ __ ] Plinko
what now I'm thinking this said Geoffrey
where they put the little marbles in the
[ __ ] fake pinball machine it's like a
style of gambling I don't know what
you're talking I may know Jamie Jamie
Jamie Jamie can we get this Japanese
gambling game up oh yeah what the [ __ ] I
was gonna say something that happened so
yeah we were getting [ __ ] rustled
around last night oh yeah by the way we
left it like three cuz we were like out
drinking mm-hmm and so we like got back
we went to bed a for basically for we
started driving like 3:30 yeah for
though pachinko
pachinko I've heard of that before
[Music]
and so we like driving in like we wake
up you know it like noon or whatever
yeah and the drivers telling and also
all these [ __ ] war stories of [ __ ]
that happened in the middle of night
well we were yeah while I was sleeping
like a baby deer and I was oh dude we're
getting into this man I woke up first of
all I woke up and I woke up at 10:00 and
I felt like kind of shitty so I'm like
oh I'll go back to sleep I didn't really
eat last night like none of us did
went back to sleep got thrown around
some more and I wake up and I'm like
sweating but it's not hot okay and I'm
like I feel like motion sickness went oh
[ __ ] some I'm pretty sure that's what I
had but then I just have like this like
steaming load just like bubbling like
there are [ __ ] nuclear alarms going
off my stomach and I'm staring out the
window just going yeah you looked bad
yeah it looks really bad yeah you know
when someone has motion sickness like
there's nothing that can pull them out
of that now there's nothing well it's
crazy it's like they're in another
[ __ ] dimension when someone has motion
sickness like you know we remember been
on the boat and [ __ ] yeah it's real
bad like it looks like they're just in a
complete another world there's looking
there staring out the window and they're
just sort of like looking at the sea
just like they flush like lost they
looked at the chifforobe bird box yeah
exactly yeah beautiful sound beautiful
just dreaming of the day where they
don't feel like they have to puke
everywhere yeah I'm just like I'm
looking at you Mike the only thing
that's gonna help him is getting off the
bus yep and so we're pulling up to the
venue and the bus slowed down I started
to feel better and I'm like just
crouched at the front of the bus like
ready to do this and I sprint to the
[ __ ] green room and boy I slam that
door and as I'm like sitting on the
toilet I'm doing this like I still feel
like I'm moving like I'm getting my
equilibrium as I'm just like and I
thought I was going for the double
header I told you this yeah I walk right
up to the toilet I'm just but nothing
came out I was like oh thank god but
then my ass was like let's go buddy turn
dad to do a quick 118 just [ __ ] plant
it and I released and I just sat there
just going like
I didn't I think I proved it maybe two
seconds I was there for like five
minutes just staring getting balance
back dude it was terrible
I had like [ __ ] sweats it was this so
awful there's so bad poop sweats yeah
yeah the old poop sweats yeah yeah I
felt like I had just like come out of
like a sauna or something like I just
like my chest was so sweaty I wasn't
wearing a shirt I had a hoodie on I felt
so bad oh my god
then we're right to the shower of the
shower
[Music]